today on the Matt Walsh show the people
who are protesting the lockdowns across
the country have been called selfish the
interesting thing is that most of the
people making that accusation have
themselves jobs and income so isn't it
rather easy when you have a job at an
income to call people selfish for
wanting their job and income back also
five headlines including Trump's
immigration moratorium which was just
announced and apparently fake flyers for
an anti-lock lockdown protest a fake
anti lockdown protest meant to discredit
the anti lock down movement have been
making their way online so we're gonna
talk about that and finally in our daily
cancellation I have to once again
unfortunately cancel someone who is very
near and dear to me so we'll get to that
coming up but first as I said thousands
of people across the country have taken
to the streets to protest the draconian
lockdown measures that have destroyed
the economy and millions of lives along
with it which is which is this
development should not be a surprise to
anyone anyone with two brain cells saw
this coming now many in the media seem
to be perplexed about this development
they just can't understand why people
will be protesting because they
themselves are doing quite well they're
still pulling an income they can still
do their cable news hits from their home
studios and so they figure what's the
big deal
they can't imagine why anybody would be
so upset about being asked to stay home
and watch Netflix and play video games
as in fact Patton Oswald the famous
comedian said in a tweet where he was
complaining and making fun of the
protesters and saying all you have to do
is stay home and play video games and
watch Netflix but those who lack the
privilege of media personalities or
famous comedians may find that Netflix
and video games if they can afford those
things at this point our poultry comfort
when they return home from waiting in
line at a food bank for six and a half
hours now agree or disagree with the
methods of the protesters the fact is
that that any reasonable and decent
person should at least understand why
they are protesting you should at least
be able to sympathize with with what has
motivated them to take this step in the
past month 22 million people have lost
their jobs and that's just the tip of
the iceberg plus another several million
who didn't qualify for unemployment
haven't applied or couldn't apply
because the websites are crashing from
all the traffic to them now contrary to
how some including dr. fowey have
characterized that these numbers 22
million unemployed this represents more
than a mere inconvenience
this this represents Americans who have
lost everything and not because of some
natural disaster or some act of God but
because the government has forbid them
from going to work now you might say
that the the reason why they've lost
their job is because of the corona virus
no that's that's not the reason that's
not the reason the reason is the direct
immediate reason is that the government
said you can't go to work and shut down
their business there was a woman at a
protest in Maryland I think a play I
showed this picture yesterday but she
held a cardboard sign saying she wanted
to save her business and I need to work
to live that's what the sign says and
that's why she's at the protest now
Democrat politicians will call that
woman selfish and talking heads on MSNBC
as one talking head did said that the
protesters are part of a death cult and
so I guess they would say of that woman
she's in a death cult but it seems to me
that she's a woman trying to salvage the
business that she's poured her sweat and
blood and tears into and so that's what
she wants to do and she wants to survive
and those seem like perfectly reasonable
goals if you ask me you can disagree
with her approach if you want though
honestly I don't see a new problem with
her approach it's a very American
approach to go and protest to make your
voice heard but to sneer at her and
other protesters as so many in the media
have done is is morally repugnant and
meanwhile these people are trying to
take trying to pretend that they have
the moral high ground that they are the
the selfless ones who are so concerned
about about sick people and so the it's
it's the the the the the they're the
selfless ones the selfish people are the
ones who are protesting a lockdown but
the truth is is the opposite of this
because almost all the people at least
in media who are making as criticism
they still have jobs and an income so
what they're saying is to the protesters
I want you to be unemployed I want you
to be forced to go to a food bank so you
can feed your kids so that I can feel
safe and so that my family can feel safe
now you can argue that all you want but
don't pretend that you're being selfless
that is a selfish position where you
want other people to suffer and
sacrifice for you so I would like to
propose an unofficial rule for any
further discussion of these protests and
lockdowns the lockdowns that prompted
them before you give your opinion you
should first have to reveal whether you
still have an income yourself before you
go on to say how you feel about the
protests how you feel about the
lockdowns you should begin by saying I
still have an income or I don't have an
income but that should be the first
thing out of your mouth because the rest
of us would like to know if you are
earning an income while you smear your
fellow Americans for wanting to earn an
income it is as I said rather striking
that the loudest voices in favor of the
shutdown are primarily people who have
lost nothing because of it it's bad
enough for those who've lost nothing to
wag their fingers at those who've lost
everything but to call them selfish that
just takes hypocrisy to a whole new
level now since I am proposing this rule
myself I should disclose the fact that I
myself am a media personality I'm still
earning an income in fact the lockdown
has been a relatively light burden on my
family I have lost money from it not a
not insignificant amount of it but I'm
still making money I still have an
income
we already homeschooled our kids and so
there was no real adjustment there we
live out in the country we got plenty of
space for our kids to go out and play
I can even still do the right the main
recreational thing I like to do which is
go fish I can still do that at least in
my state I'm still out at least where I
currently
I'm allowed to do that or at least they
haven't stopped me from doing it and you
know I personally tend to be a bit of a
hermit anyway so isolation from from the
general public for me is no great horror
so that's the position I'm in have an
income got it you know and I'm working
from home and you know our we've had to
adjust but it hasn't been
it hasn't been a hue I wouldn't call it
a huge sacrifice for us now if the
economy continues to crater and we line
we wind up in a full-on depression then
I certainly will not be immune from the
consequences of that very few of us will
be immune from those consequences I will
not be immune my family won't be immune
so we could down the road we could be in
line to make enormous sacrifices as well
but as of right now I'm doing all right
here's my point I realize that not
everybody is in my shoes
not everybody can work from home I don't
know why for other for so many others in
the media why is this such a difficult
thing to understand I'm not some sort of
great humanitarian for having this this
attitude it's just it's a bits of bait
it's it's it's logic is all it is but
that's all I understand that I can work
around not everybody can not everyone
can so easily isolate themselves from
society
some people have real jobs that require
them to go out and do things we and we
still need that in society it's a good
thing we could never be a society where
everybody can work from there our people
have to go out and physically do things
out in the real world and many of them
are not allowed to do that now so what
has been a light burden for me has been
a crushing weight for so many others Who
am I to call people selfish for wanting
income and stability when I already have
those things
so if I'm going to be outraged at anyone
my outrage should be directed not at
them but at the government that has done
this to them speaking of the government
the moral outrage here is compounded by
the fact that people in government just
like people in meat in the media are
still living comfortable lives living in
relative luxury while regular Americans
lose everything
now I think that Congress they should
have to forfeit their pay they shouldn't
be making a paycheck throughout
throughout all of this but of course
that would require them to pass some
sort of rule or something or at least to
volunteer to lose their pay and they're
not going to do that because all of this
stuff they talk about it but we have to
make sacrifices we're all in this
together oh shut up
you're not making any sacrifices you're
making even fewer sacrifices than I am
because you're also in government so I
along with everybody else I've lost
liberty and freedom you have gained
power so you keep your income while many
people lose theirs while many people
lose their liberties you gain power so
it's not just that you haven't
sacrificed in government you have gained
from it now this dichotomy was captured
I think a dramatic fashion in an ad that
the Trump campaign released last night
this is truly one of the most
devastating political ads I've ever seen
in my life so just buckle up for this
watch we turn now to that three hundred
and fifty billion dollar fund to help
small businesses and its workers get
through the shutdown it will be up to
Congress to restock it but Democrats
blocking that move this morning they
asked for a quarter of a trillion
dollars in 48 hours I don't think so
and they objected and I congratulate the
Senate Democrat Speaker Pelosi what are
you gonna share with us from your home
chocolate candy thousands have been
forced to wait for hours at food banks
all across the country
oh stop it and then we have some other
chocolate here we just got it restock
the ice cream you don't want to eat up
everything know it at one time I can't
do it much longer I am trying so hard
can we say enjoying having to admit that
yeah what we're starving and I like it
better than anything else
taping this segment there are 22 million
people out this specific program is
about stopping job losses today other
people and our family look for some
other flavors but I know it's survivable
you don't know where next something else
about come from I don't know what I
would have done if ice cream were not
invented I just wondered Wow first of
all politically that is brutal brutal
and deservedly so it captures it the
important truth that all of the
sacrifices that are being made are being
made by regular citizens and that is a
it's a pretty profound illustration
there when you when you see and you see
this contrast between people or waiting
in lines at food banks that stretch
literally miles okay we're talking about
lines at food banks that are miles long
and while that is happening Nancy Pelosi
has her $24,000 fridge stocked with ice
cream the people behind these lockdown
policies and those who support the
policies do not appreciate the toll that
these policies are taking on regular
citizens and I think that is a very
relevant fact here's another great
example as the price of oil was tanking
yesterday
Alexandria Kaiser Cortez couldn't help
herself she has since deleted this but
this is what she tweeted you could see
it right here you absolutely love to see
it
she says you love to see it many America
they're gonna lose their jobs that many
Americans already have now because of
this many more Americans would lose a
job this is going to have a devastating
effect especially in places like Texas
and Louisiana America is going to lose
their livelihoods over it and aoc loves
to see it she loves to see Americans
losing their jobs because it's no skin
off her nose she's still got her job
everything's fine for her she's living
her life living her truth and meanwhile
she sees this as advantageous for her
ideological agenda which is green energy
and this is the attitude that the people
in government have so maybe you begin to
see why there are these protests one
other point I want to make about
lockdowns and ending the lockdowns and
everything and we'll talk about that in
just a second but first a word from our
friends over at zip recruiter now you
know zip recruiter they they've you you
want to talk about helping employers and
helping in the workforce super kurt has
been doing that for a long time and
that's why rather than the typical
advertisement they've got a special
message that they want to pass along to
you and to everybody in in the middle of
this crisis so here's a message from our
sponsor at zip recruiter right now we
cannot be overwhelmed we have to work to
keep our loved ones safe and protect our
communities we have to work to stay
strong to stay connected to stay focused
we have to work to inspire to innovate
to build new solutions but for all this
to work we have to work together a
zipper cruder we connect employers and
people every day but today is different
we are partnering with first responders
government officials the medical
community the innovator is a
manufacturing transportation and food
distribution industries to make sure we
are finding the right people for the
right job right now let's work together
zip recruiter dot-com / work together
all right one other point I wanted to
make about these lock downs and
specifically ending the lock downs
because you know
should I keep hearing is that what we
let people go out maybe there are the
there may be people there are lots of
people certainly who want to go back to
work so they can feed their families and
as the argument goes okay that's all
well and good but you and maybe you want
to take on that risk but now you're
forcing other people to take that risk
because you're gonna spread it to them
and so isn't this isn't that so that's
not fair right and this is the response
to the argument that people should be
allowed to take on a risk if they want
to so they can work and feed their
families there are all kinds of risks
that we take in life and generally will
we let adults decide if that's a risk
that they think is worth taking but the
response is aren't you forcing other
people to take the risk too because you
can spread it and that's why I want to
say that while I just to clarify here
and I I think I can speak for most
people who support ending the lockdowns
I haven't heard anyone take the opposite
view on this so this is my my view we
end the lockdowns allowing people to
leave their homes again and most
importantly go to work so that they can
support their families that's that's the
position that's that's what we're
advocating allowing people leave them
here's the point we're not saying that
people should be forced to leave their
home I I certainly don't think that I
don't think you should be mandated to
leave your home I just think you should
be allowed to in the United States of
America and especially when you can't
afford food to feed your kids so I think
that that really addresses the that
concern doesn't it of someone going to
work taking the risk but then spreading
it if you don't want to leave your house
don't leave your house if you want to
stay locked in your home for another six
months or a year you're free to do that
if it mean if you can find a way right
if you if you
if you're making it through the lockdown
okay right now you're working from home
or whatever and you felt then and you
want to keep doing that keep doing it so
what's the problem here
people who want to leave their homes and
participate in society can and if you
don't want to add I don't even mean this
in a combative way I really this is very
sincere if you're still worried about
you're still afraid maybe for good
reason maybe you have pre-existing
conditions maybe you're in in in one of
the vulnerable categories well in that
case I wouldn't blame you at all I think
it's a very good idea to stay even if
the lock downs are lifted maybe you stay
for as long as you can depending on your
situation depending on what your
pre-existing condition is right
depending on where you live - so there
are a lot of factors that work into this
but if you're in in that category then
then you know you may be you stay home
you continue to self isolate and I also
think as I've said before that people
who are in those vulnerable neural
groups we should keep helping them and
the government should help them and it'd
be a lot easier to do rather than giving
checks to everybody even people don't
need it if we can target if we can be a
lot more targeted in our approach
helping people who actually have to stay
home because of pre-existing conditions
okay so I think that that kind of
addresses that issue that those people
can continue to self isolate as I've
said many times you know nursing home
should remain lockdown of course for it
for the foreseeable future because we
know how devastating this has been in
nursing homes and then anybody else
maybe you don't have a pre-existing
condition maybe you're younger and
healthy but you just are afraid of it
you don't want to go out of your house
well I'm not saying you should be forced
to you could stay home to the people who
feel like they need to or want to to get
back out and resume their lives should
be allowed to do that all right let's
move on to news headlines number one
President Trump sent out a tweet
yesterday with an announcement in light
of the attack this is this is his tweet
says in light of the attack from the
invisible enemy as well as the need to
protect the jobs of our great American
citizens I will be
an executive order to temporarily
suspend immigration in the United States
this apparently will be a moratorium on
immigration through the southern border
obviously it makes sense to do this my
only problems that he didn't do it two
months ago but or maybe even two years
ago frankly but the general idea is
clearly clearly good now of course as
you might expect some on the Left are
calling it bigoted yada yada etc and so
forth but that is just a very stupid
unserious position to take here and it
can be ignored and should be ignored
especially coming from people who up to
this point haven't met a government
action in response to the virus that
they didn't like shutting down churches
arresting people for you know going to
drive-in services closing up playgrounds
and parks and beaches oh yeah I love all
that but no stopping people from coming
in from foreign countries in the middle
of pandemic no that's too far we can't
do that oh that's that's one government
action that definitely unassailably
makes sense now we're gonna move on to
number two but before we do that a word
from our friends over venom brothers you
know when you start having your
employees working remote you have to
manage your workforce and also your work
flow really well and in that case
systems are very crucial the Bennett
brothers are great at managing work
teams that are all over the country this
is what they do these guys have over a
dozen businesses including a real estate
empire that spans over 35 states now
that might that name might ring a bell
the Benham brothers because they were
slated for you might remember this story
that were stated for a reality TV show
on HGTV and they were cancelled because
of their commitment to conservative
values so they're really great guys and
they were willing no they you think
about how great it must be especially in
this business to have that show on HGTV
they were willing to sacrifice that for
their convictions which i think is just
spectacular
over the last six months these guys have
been working on a new course called
expert ownership how to own a business
without owning it without it owning you
and in it they teach entrepreneurs and
small business owners the exact system
that they themselves have used to build
their businesses over time so if you're
sitting at home trying to run your
business right now
expert ownership was made for you the
Benham brothers slashed the cost of the
course to help small business owners and
entrepreneurs who are trying to navigate
all that's happening right now so head
over to Benham brothers dot-com slash
walsh to see a preview of the course and
get a special discount that's benh a.m.
brothers dot-com slash walsh okay number
two as we've covered here several times
cities around the country including in
New York have been releasing prisoners
back into the population in order to in
order to protect them that would be the
prisoners not the population and after
weeks of this insane suicidal policy New
York and other cities have developed a
problem where in the released criminals
are going right back to being criminals
and starting to commit crimes again
because that's what they do it's their
whole thing you might say well Mayor
Bill DeBlasio of New York spoke about
this about the released prisoners
committing crimes again during a
briefing this week and this is what he
said I think it's unconscionable just on
a human level that folks were shown
mercy and this is what some of them have
done unconscionable he says now
unconscionable means that something is
shocking shockingly bad so Mayor Bill
DeBlasio who to emphasize was elected
mayor of New York City our largest city
thinks it's shocking that criminals
would commit crimes after being given a
get out of jail free card card he's
shocked by this didn't see it coming
didn't see it now no way
you're telling me we'll wait those
criminals we released are committing
crimes what that's just unconscionable
now for most leftists who are claiming
to be shocked by something like this
I would I would say that that's bogus
and and obviously they're not really
shocked they knew that was gonna happen
but de Blasio is such a dumb goober that
I might actually buy it I think he might
actually be that stupid that this is
that this surprises him number three
reading now from The Daily wire says in
a press release issued Monday the Los
Angeles County Department of Public
Health announced that the early results
of its highly into
a joint study with the university of
southern california ANCOVA 19 infections
in the county suggests that infections
from the new corona virus are far more
widespread and they fatality rate much
lower in LA County than previously
thought and that goes into the numbers
you can read the report in The Daily
wire but the point is a lot more people
have it than then has previously been
reported which obviously is good news
it's good news because that means that
number one the fatality rate rates if
this holds true across the country the
fatality rate is much lower than what
they're reporting and it also means that
there are probably many states where the
crisis has already passed because so
many people have already had it and
they've already seen the worst of it so
number four this is something you need
to watch out for maybe you've seen this
picture that I'll show you now floating
around social media I've seen it many
times and when I've heard the first time
I saw it immediately I thought something
doesn't look right here this is a photo
of a flyer from an anti lockdown protest
in New York and the flyer says end the
lockdown rally no masks needed bring
your children non-essential workers if
you're sick still come it's your rights
Sunday April 19th Conference House lawn
Keep America great Magga hashtag end the
shutdown NYC now the left has been
making hay with this because it proves
right it proves that the anti lockdown
people are a bunch of suicidal Magga
cult maniacs actually encouraging sick
people to come telling people not to
wear masks and even throwing in you know
bring your children but as I said I saw
this and immediately my BS detector went
off now sure it's it's possible that
some actual maniac was crazy enough to
put this flyer up and try to plan a
rally in fighting sick people to come
that's possible but it is not very
likely because despite how they're
portrayed by the media the anti lockdown
folks are not a bunch of comic book
villains okay this is not Joker putting
these these events on
so the fact that this flyer feeds right
into the caricature of the of the
protesters that the media presents
should tell you something
it should raise a red flag and it tells
you that this is probably fake so I
looked into it myself and first of all
this rally was supposed to be on Sunday
nobody showed up apparently according to
reports nobody came not one person
now if this was a rally actually being
organized by some group or some person
they at least would be at the rally I've
been to plenty of political rallies of
protests in my day that were sparsely
attended but the one thing you can
always count on is the people who
organized it will be there at least
oftentimes looking very embarrassed that
nobody else came but they're gonna be
there so if nobody came what does that
tell you it tells you that nobody
organized it it wasn't a real rally uh
then also the hash tag on the flyer a
hash tag was it in the shutdown NYC or
whatever it was I checked that hash tag
and nobody had tweeted the hash tag
there were two tweets with that hash tag
and they were both making fun of the
flyer now if you're organizing an event
and you come up with a hashtag for it
the whole point of the hash tag is that
you're gonna tweet on that hashtag to
try to promote the event that's the
whole point but there are no tweets
which would so why are we supposed to
believe that somebody was organizing
this event they came up with a hashtag
they went around posting flyers around
town they never once posted on Twitter
hey end the show at that NYC hashtag
whatever no that doesn't make any sense
also no group claimed credit for this or
you know there's no name attached no
website attached to it so factoring all
that together what does it mean it means
that this is fake like this is like
99.9% fake I'll allow for a point one
percent chance that it's real but 99.9
percent this is fake and that tells you
that the other side of this debate
they are resorting to some devious
tactics including fake fliers for fake
rallies to try to discredit those who
want to end the shutdown and that you
know that should really
make you weary and when you start seeing
media reports about rallies and things
you just keep this in mind if you see if
you if you see footage of a rally and
you see somebody with a really
inappropriate or weird or crazy looking
sign or something you have to think is
that person actually part of that rally
or is that someone who's there to
discredit so that should tell you that
number five speaking of things that
smell funny to doctors were on a
coronavirus podcast this week and they
were talking about the dangers that
farts posed during this pandemic now one
doctor dr. Swann and his net is his name
he said that it might be possible for
the virus to be spread through your
southerly winds which is why it's
recommended that and this is very
important to health recommendations here
are that if you're gonna fart make sure
you wear pants which you know is so it
might be it's a little bit of a burden
there but but again we all have to make
sacrifices and so you know generally if
you're out in public you want to be
wearing pants anyway but especially
during these times I would say now this
is what the doctor said quote I think
that we should what we should do in
terms of social distancing and being
safe is that you don't fart close to
other people and that you don't fart
with your bottom bare so this is we're
talking about fart social distancing
social fart distancing and anyway this
is one measure that I can certainly get
behind or rather I guess I'd rather be
out in front of it but anyway this is
all to say we need to quarantine Eric's
wall well ASAP before it's too late
moving on to your daily cancellation
today I'm once again unfortunately gonna
have to cancel I hate to do it I really
do but I'm have to cancel my wife again
and this is I think it was a second or
third time I've canceled her on the show
and I'll tell you why and you're gonna
agree with my decision once you once you
like once you hear what she did so
yesterday I had the brilliant idea to
give my both of my sons
I was gonna give him a buzz cut okay
three years old and six years old are my
sons and they both look at this point
because they haven't had a haircut like
the rest of us and so they look like
they're wearing mops on their heads or
like or maybe something like some sort
of woodland creature crawl on top of
their heads and died and so I said you
know this is not good
it's not good for their self-esteem it's
not good for me cuz I have to look at it
it's not good for hygiene you know and
and the corona virus can hide up in the
hair you know I've read that too so I
said to my wife all cut their hair now I
happen to be a celebrated stylist so I
figured this idea would go over well
with my wife but she recoiled for some
reason actually she refused to allow my
oldest son to go anywhere near me with
with when I had the Clippers because
Luke my oldest has blonde curly hair
which my wife is very protective of in
fact he didn't get any kind of haircut
even a professional haircut I think it
till he was like four years old and so
by the time he was four he had like
these long golden heels I got like a
hippie with a perm here this was a
ridiculous looking hair and finally he
got a haircut so she said I can't cuts
Luke's hair but my youngest son Jeremiah
was offered up as a sacrifice much like
Abraham offering Isaac my my wife
offered the three-year-old up to the
slaughter and but she doubted me the
whole time she critiqued harassed me and
it is for this doubt this lack of faith
this lack of loyalty that she was being
canceled and ultimately she was put to
shame because my my son's hair turned
out beautifully
honestly the kids never looked so good I
was masterful I discovered with him
within myself not only a natural ability
as a hair stylist but frankly a passion
for it I think I might quit my job and
become a hair stylist full-time I just
discovered this something I'm very good
at so here take a look here's a picture
I blurred out his face because I don't
want him on I don't want his face on
camera but here's I just want you to see
the work that I did this is the haircut
yeah that's pretty good you have to bit
notice the fading of the size the way I
blended it all together you know they
spent ten years teaching this in Hair
Stylist school ten years I mastered it
in five minutes and you can see
yes kind of the the edgy sort of styling
that I did up top they're kind of a
messy spiky but still classy look right
so it looks like he's ready for a
business meeting but he's also ready to
go out and play on the playground and
that's kind of what I was going for so I
just thought I did a fantastic job and
now my next goal is to give my daughter
a haircut I don't know if that's gonna
go over well or not but I but the point
is I have a I have apparently I have a
real passion for fashion and a skill and
so that's why my wife is canceled
and you know what else is canceled bad
hair all right in this house bad hair is
canceled okay now we go to emails and I
got a why I'm wrong email here now I
feel like it's getting repetitive here
with these corner virus emails telling
you why I'm a monster who wants to kill
kill the elderly but this is it's just
the it's the same point repeated over
and over again this is from Justin says
hi Matt I've been very disappointed with
your corona virus Takes recently it's
hard for me not to see it as highly
selfish yes you're young and healthy but
not everybody is if you're going out in
public and you have the virus you could
be directly killing multiple people
would you press a button to kill three
people just so you can get your normal
life back that's what it's like this is
this is actually the second or third
time I've specifically seen this press a
button thing someone tweeted that to me
yesterday they're going out in public
during the corona virus or going back to
your normal life going your job is like
pressing a button and killing people I
don't know if this is the latest this is
the latest argument it's like pressing a
button no it's not like that at all so
there's a a few problems here that we
have to go through first of all even if
I was sick and I went out in public it
would not be exactly the same as
pressing a button and directly killing
it's not the same when you're sick now
if you're sick and you intentionally
tried to infect other people and then
they died from the illness then I would
say that's effectively the same as
shooting them sure I agree with you
there but if you're
sic and you go out and you
unintentionally infect somebody else
it's morally not the same as shooting
them in the head it's just not it is not
it isn't you're not directly responsible
you're not you're not directly and
intentionally killing someone and
there's a big difference there so just
just to be clear there's a big
difference between intentionally killing
someone by shooting them or pressing a
button or accidentally getting them sick
now am I saying that if you're sick with
the quarter virus you should go out in
public of course not that would be
reckless stupid yes it would be selfish
would be all of those things and if you
know you you are sick with a potentially
deadly virus and you go out in public
and you get somebody else sick then yes
I do think you're partially responsible
for for killing them but it's just it's
ethically not the same as directly
shooting somebody that so or pressing a
button or whatever it is pressing a
button and I guess what blowing them up
or I don't know how this button thing is
supposed to work so that's that's the
first thing but I am not advocating that
if you know you're sick that you go out
in public it's not what I'm saying
that's that's not the discussion here in
fact part of my not just me but part of
the proposal of opening up society is
that if you're sick and you have
symptoms of course you stay home we we
quarantine people who are sick or who we
know have been exposed to the virus and
that's actually what a quarantine is
supposed to be so what I'm saying is we
should have actual quarantine policies
quarantine and isolation if you're sick
you're isolated if you if we know you've
been exposed to someone who's sick like
somebody in your house is sick okay so
we know you've been exposed to it and
especially in a prolonged way where the
chance of transmission is pretty high
then then we quarantine you so I'm
totally in favor of actual quarantines
and and and isolation policies what I'm
not in favor of is a blanket policy
imposed by the government locking
everybody in their homes even people who
for all for as far as we know are
healthy people who we have no reason or
no evidence to think that they that they
are sick or that they've
exposed and then in the process
cratering the economy and causing
millions of people lose their jobs and
causing them to have to go to food banks
and and everything else okay that's what
I'm against that's my issue and as far
as the the risk of infecting somebody
else listen I go back to what I said
before that anyone who does not want to
take a risk and if we do this right and
we're smart about it it's not a very
significant risk now I realize that
people as far as we know pre-symptomatic
people can still spread the virus we
don't know how effectively they can
spread it probably not very effectively
but we can do it we can go a long way to
stopping the spread by keeping people
who have symptoms at home and so if we
if we do that we still practice social
distancing I'm in favor of wearing masks
you know especially in certain
environments I don't you know I don't
think I should have to wear a mask when
you're walking down the down the street
or going for a jog or something in the
park but if you're in a crowded
environment I think it makes sense to
our masks of course and so if we do that
we keep the elderly people at home
people who are especially vulnerable we
keep them at home and if you yourself
don't want to go out you don't want to
take that risk you don't have to you're
welcome to stay home and and that means
that everybody who's out and about in
society is because they've decided that
it's worth it to them it's worth it to
take that minimal risk maybe it's worth
it because they just want to go about
their lives maybe it's worth it because
they feel like they have to work to live
which I totally understand and there we
go and I so so I think that that this
idea that some it could be spread to
someone who has no interest in being out
in society and taking the minimal risk
well I don't see that because they can
still stay home so what exactly is the
issue here I don't see it but thanks for
the email and we'll wrap it up there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 even left-wing mayors are
beginning to admit the experts got it
wrong way more people have the virus
than they thought way fewer people are
dying from it and the lockdowns likely
aren't doing very much to stop it at all
then the price of oil plummets to
negative $40 cancel culture claims
another scalp and Kim jong-un might be
brain dead all that and more check it
out on the Michael Nolt show
[Music]